The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So, any
questions from last time?
We started doing
reaction mechanisms.
We did first order
parallel reactions.
So one of the things
that we'll be stressing
is that the mechanisms
that we write down
are ways to try to understand
a complicated chemical process.
And you take data, you can
find intermediates sometimes.
And you get rate
laws from the data.
You infer rate laws.
And from these rate
laws, you think up
of a reaction mechanism and you
make sure that what you measure
is consistent with
your mechanism
that you make up to explain the
complicated chemical process.
And one really important
thing to remember
is that when you come
up with a mechanism
and you've got a bunch of data
that supports it, it's great.
But it doesn't mean that
you've solve the problem.
It doesn't mean
that you've proven
that the way that the
chemistry proceeds
is really the way it proceeds.
Because there's
always the possibility
that there's an intermediate
somewhere in there
that you haven't
been able to measure.
And a lot of people
got tripped up
over the course of
the last century,
of making up mechanisms, getting
a lot of data that supports
the mechanism and missing
something really important.
So it's a common
mistake, that people
think they've proven
a particular chemical
mechanism just because they
have data that supports it.
It's up to a certain point
that you know what you have.
And we'll see examples
of that today, probably.
And then certainly
next time when
we start making approximations
in our kinetics.
And see where things
can really go wrong
if you don't have enough data.
If you don't try
to fish out really,
really, tiny intermediates
somewhere along the way.
So last time we did then
parallel first order reactions.
And today we're going
to march through and do
parallel first and second order.
So one is first order, the
other one is second order.
Things are going to
get more complicated.
And what you're going
to get is a flavor
of how to solve the problems.
Setting up the problems.
We're not going to do a lot of
the algebra here on the board,
because otherwise we
would spend the next three
weeks doing algebra.
And that would be no fun at all.
That doesn't mean
that you're not
going to be doing any
algebra on the homework.
Because part of it is
figuring how to do it.
So, we have a reaction
where A goes to B plus C.
And the first thing we did
was, the first mechanism
we wrote was a parallel
mechanism where
we had A goes B and A goes
to C. That's the mechanism.
And one other way to write
it is A goes to B or C,
in a way that is more,
sort of describes
the branching
process, that when we
talk about a branching ratio,
the ratio of amount of B to C,
this looks like the branching
out of two different paths.
And this time we're going to
do where this is first order
and this is second order.
With the rate k1 and a rate k2.
And the way that you
do all these problems,
you have to be very
systematic about it.
The first thing
you do is you have
to write down all
your rate laws.
And make sure that you
include everything.
So you start by writing the rate
law for the destruction of A.
And then the rate law for the
appearance of B and for C.
So for a, we have dA/dt.
And again, I'm dropping
the brackets around the A,
because I don't want to carry
around all these extra symbols.
So we destroy A by making B. So
that's going to be first order.
And then we also
destroy A by making C,
and that's second order.
So we have two paths out
of A. To get rid of A.
Then we write down the
appearance of B, dB/dt.
It's only through one
path, first order in A,
and then the appearance
of C, only one path
which is second order.
And these are all our
differential equations.
And now the trick is, how do you
solve these three differential
equations in a way that you
get meaningful information out.
Well, the first
thing to do is to,
so these two here depend on
A. So the appearance of B
depends on A, the appearance
of C depends on A.
But this one here only
depends on A by itself.
So this is the first one
you're going to start out with.
Because you can
put all of the A's
on one side and all the time on
the other side and integrate.
So then you solve, and
you can rewrite this
as minus dA/dt is equal to
k1 times A times one plus k2
over k1 times A. And then you
put all the A's on one side,
all the t's on the other side.
And integrate from A0 to A minus
dA over A times one plus k2
over k1 times A. That is
equal to k1 from zero to t dt.
And then you have to
solve this integral here.
And there's a reason why
I factored out the A here.
It's because this
is of the form you
can use to use the trick
of partial fractions, which
we mentioned this before.
So you use partial
fractions to solve this.
And I'm not going to
do it on the board.
You turn the crank,
you basically
write one over A times
one plus k2 over k1 A
is equal to n1 of A plus
n2 over this part here,
and you solve for n1 and
n2 and you plug it back in,
and you redo your
integral, et cetera.
And you get your answer.
Which I'm going to
write down because I'm
going to use it
later. k1 A0 over e
to the k1 times
t, k1 plus k2 A0.
So one of the things
we immediately see
is even though this mechanism
isn't very complicated,
just two paths, one first order,
one second order, the solutions
start to get not so
simple pretty quickly.
So it depends, there's an
exponential on the bottom here.
Depends on the initial
concentrations and both rate
constants are in there.
The first thing
you want to do is
you want to look
at limiting cases.
Just like before.
We did, and the
first limiting case
we're going to look at,
so interesting to look at
is this guy right
here. k1 and k2 A here.
If one is bigger than the other,
then things will cancel out.
And we can get some intuition.
So the first limiting case
we're going to look at
is where k2 A0, this term right
here, is much smaller than k1.
Now, we want to make sure
that in these limiting cases
that when I write something like
this, that the units actually
make sense.
That I'm not
saying, three apples
are less than four oranges.
So k1, it's first
order, so the units
are one over second. k2, it's
a second order rate constant,
so the units are one over second
molar, times moles per liter.
So the moles per
liters cancel out
and I have one over our second
is less than one over second,
so things are great.
It I'm making the right
kind of approximation here.
What else is this
approximation saying?
This is saying that the
rate into B, so this one is
the faster one. k1, the rate
into B, is the rate into,
is k1, is faster than k2 times
A, which is basically the rate
into C. So this is saying that
the rate into B, to form B,
is faster than into C. So
we can write down a sketch.
We can sketch what we expect
this approximation to be, then.
And we know it's going to
look something like this.
We know that A is going to
come down, exponentially.
Without any structure to it.
It's going to go either
into B or into C,
in some branching fractions.
And we know that the rate
into B is faster than into C,
so B is going to
come up like this.
And C is going to
come up, but slower.
And there's going to be a
ratio between these two guys.
So we know the slope here
is going to be slower
then the slope for B. And
we can check that out,
within our approximation.
We can write, at t
equals zero, find out
what these initial slopes are.
For the creation of
B and C. So dB/dt
is the slope of the creation
of B at the beginning.
At t equals zero.
And that's just the
rate law. dB/dt at t
equals zero is k1 A0.
And dC/dt, the initial slope, t
equals zero, is k1 A0 squared.
Or k2 A0 squared, rather.
So I'm going to write it as
k2 A0 squared, like this.
We said k1 is much
bigger than k2 times A0.
There's the same A0 here.
So we see, just by
writing this down,
that our intuition that
because the rate into B
is much faster than into A,
that it should look like this.
Well it's borne out just
like this very simple sort
of looking at the initial
rate where the slope here
is much smaller
than the slope here.
And then we can take the
approximation in here.
And see what it implies.
So let me do that here, let me
just use my green chalk here.
So k2 A0 is much less than k1.
So this is going to go away.
k2 A0 is much less than k1.
Well, this is
building up from zero.
So this is always
bigger than one here.
So I can get rid
of this as well.
Because there's the
k1 sitting here.
And k1 is much
bigger than k2 A0.
Once I got rid of all these two
guys, then the k1's cancel out.
And this is looking very nice.
Because now I can take that e
to the k1 t and put it upstairs.
A is equal to approximately
A0 e to the minus k1 times
time in this approximation.
It looks like it's
first order coming down,
with a rate constant k1.
It looks like basically
the branching into C
is nonexistent as far as, at
least in this approximation,
as far A is concerned.
It's going to look
like this thing here.
like first order
A goes to B with
rate constant k1.
So if you didn't
know, if you didn't
know that there was
another substance, C,
that was being formed along the
way, if you didn't measure it,
if you didn't do the analytical
chemistry and sort of fish it
out, and you just looked at the
two major components, A and B,
in this case here, you'd
measure a rate out of A,
it would look like
it's first order.
It's great.
Got my mechanism.
A goes to B, period.
And you would know there
was a minor component that
was being formed
at the same time.
OK, let's do another
approximation.
Let's do the other case, where
k2 A0 is much bigger than k1.
And, in this case
here, you have to be
a little bit more careful.
You have to add
that you're going
to look at this at early times.
And we're going to see why
early times is important here.
In just five minutes.
And early times, and how
you define early times.
What does it mean for things to
be close to time equals zero?
Well, we have to have
a reference time scale.
The reactions, I'm
going at a certain rate.
And one second may be very slow.
Or it may be very fast.
Depending on the
rate of the reaction.
So k1 here defines the
time scale of the problem.
It's one over second,
unit of one over second.
And early times means that
the times that I'm looking at
compare to this rate,
it's very small.
So k1 t is less than one.
That means that the time,
during the time period that I'm
looking at, hardly anything has
happened to the branching of A
to B. That that's what
I mean by early time.
So B is hardly being built
up yet. k1 is our reference
time. k1 is units
of one over second.
This has units of seconds.
So it's all working out fine.
In other words, I would have no
idea how to define early times.
I could say, it's in
a year, it could be,
if you're looking
at plutonium decay,
it's a 100,000 year half-life.
A year would be an early time.
So it would be really fast,
compared to the process.
But if you're looking
at a reaction that
takes a few nanoseconds than a
year would be very, very long.
So you really need
your reference time
somewhere in there.
So this approximation means
that essentially, no B
is being created.
While we're looking
at the process.
And so we might then
very well expect
that if we look at A and
C, that the answer is going
to be that we're going to see
something that's second order.
So we expect that the form
of A, the way to write it
is going to be one over
A equals k1 t plus A0.
So let's go ahead and
take our complete solution
and write it in the way that we
might expect the answer to be.
In terms of one over
A rather than A here.
So let's just invert it. e to
the k1 times time, k1 plus k2
A0, minus k2 A0 over k1 A0.
This should be a
minus sign here.
There should be a
It didn't matter for
our approximation
because we got rid
of it anyway, but it
would be a proper
sign here is minus.
And so now we need to
make our approximation
and figure out what this here.
So if we take the approximation
that k1 t is small, less
than one, then what that
should trigger in your mind
if that if you have e to
the something that small
you should use a Taylor series.
And expand this into
a Taylor series.
So we're going to see
this multiple times.
So we take e to the k1 t
and expand it out as one
plus k1 t plus et cetera.
We're going to keep the
first order terms in there.
So we're going to plug this
approximation into here.
That's this approximation there.
And then we're going
to expand it out.
So plug it in here, and, keeping
it to first order in time,
and multiplying it
out, and I'm not
going to do the
intermediate steps,
I'm just going to give
you the stuff after doing
the multiplications,
we get k1 t squared.
So that's basically k1
times one plus k1 t,
and then you have
plus k1 k2 A0 times t.
That's this term here. k1
k2 A0 times t times that.
And the k2 A0 times
one gets subtracted out
from this minus k2 A0 here.
So that's all we have on top.
And then there are terms
of higher order in time.
But we're not going
to worry about this.
We're going to stick
to first order in time.
Divided by k1 A0.
And now you do
your cancellations.
We have our
approximation at k1 times
time is much less than one.
So here we have k1
times k1 times time.
So this term here means it's
much less than this term
here, because of
our approximations.
So we can get rid
of this term here.
Get rid of that.
There's no reason for us to
get rid of this one here.
Because we've got k2 A0 there,
which is much larger than k1.
And so when you expand this out,
all the k1's cancel out here.
So so k1 cancels out that
k1, we have one plus one.
So this is basically
one over A0.
And then we have plus
k2 A0 time over A0,
so this ends up being equal to
one over A0 plus k2 times time.
Exactly what we expected.
That if you put in the right
approximation in the math,
it behaves as your
intuition would tell you.
Which is that the branching
into B nonexistent.
And that you're looking
at everything going to C.
It looks second order
in C. But in this case
here, it's only early times.
So if you keep
going, what happens?
If you keep going in
time, beyond the time
scale of this first
order rate constant,
and you wait long enough,
then the amount of A
keeps decreasing.
Keeps getting
smaller and smaller.
So if you start the clock
again, a little bit later,
where A is much
smaller, then k2 times
the amount of A you
have there, is no longer
going to be much
greater than k1.
At some point along
the way, k2 times A
is going to be
much less than k1.
So at some point
along the way, it's
not going to be this
approximation any more.
It's going to be the
previous one that we did.
The one up there.
So at early times we
start with something
that may look second order for
A. Time goes on, time goes on,
time goes on, A gets depleted.
A gets depleted, and
the rate k2 times
A, which is sitting right
here, this part here
becomes smaller and smaller.
And pretty soon this part wins.
And it becomes first order.
So what you'd
expect to see, then,
is if you were to plot
as a function of A,
you expect to see something
that starts out as first order
and then as A gets depleted,
switches over to second order.
Something that's
second order here.
And first order.
This is the concentration of
A. So if you were to plot it,
here you're plotting
the concentration of A.
If you were to plot the log,
of the concentration of A,
at long times you'd expect
it to be first order.
So something linear.
But at early times you'd
expect it to be second order.
So you'd expect to see
something that's nonlinear,
then switching to
something linear.
And if you were to
plot it as one over A,
then you'd expect to start off
with something that's linear,
at second order, early times.
But instead of keeping,
being second order,
as you deplete the amount
of A, the branching into B
becomes important.
And you become second order.
So this is second
order at the beginning.
And this becomes first order.
So, any questions here?
The importance of
doing this problem
here was to lay out
basically a systematic way
of looking at the problem.
You lay out your rate equations.
Like this.
You solve what you can, in
this case you solve for A.
And it's complicated.
So you want to learn
something about what
the data might look like.
And you look at limiting cases.
Two obvious limiting cases.
One rate is faster
than the other.
You pick the first one
first, then go through it.
And then use your intuition.
Every point along the
way, your intuition
can tell you what you
expect the result to be.
So in this case
here, our intuition
told us that if we
took the rate into B
to be much faster
than that into C,
than we expected
to see something
that was largely first order.
And when you we
the approximation
in our exact solution,
in fact it does
look like it's first order.
So always use your intuition.
Because the math is going
to get pretty hairy.
The algebra might
make it complicated.
And it's really easy
to make a plus sign
into a minus sign
somewhere along the way.
Just like I did here.
So if I hadn't fixed
my mistake here,
and I had gone and put
in my Taylor series here,
I would have gotten in trouble.
Because this minus sign
would have been a plus.
And these k2 A0's would
not have canceled out.
And I wouldn't have gotten
the right result, which
my intuition had told me should
be a second order process.
And so if you have a problem,
let's say you're on an exam
and you're doing algebra,
you're trying to,
and you end up
with a result that
doesn't match what your
intuition tells you,
and you don't have
time to fix it.
Tell us.
You know, I know this
is wrong because I
know it's supposed
to be second order.
But I don't know
where I went wrong.
And that's really important.
Just tell us.
That means that you're thinking.
Let's get a little
bit more complicated.
Any questions?
Consecutive series reactions.
These were parallel
reactions and now.
Basically what
we're doing here is
we're building up a toolkit
of simple mechanisms.
And then we'll be able to
put these mechanisms together
to make something
more complicated.
So the next kind of mechanism,
series mechanism, series
reactions, so we
have our reaction.
Which is A goes to
C. And the mechanism
that's been thought
for this reaction
is that there's an intermediate.
That first you have A goes to
B, some intermediate, which gets
used up to form the final
product, C, with a rate, k2,
here.
And we can either write
the mechanism in two steps.
Or we can write it as A goes
to B goes to C, like this.
And see both ways of writing it.
And we want to solve this.
And we want to look
at special cases,
and we just want to
understand the implications
of this mechanism.
So the first thing to do,
just like we did before,
is to write all the rate laws.
Before we got going
solving anything.
So we start with A, minus dA/dt.
There's only one way
that gets used up.
Through the formation of B
in a first order process.
Easy.
This is easy to solve.
We know the answer is going
to be exponential in it.
For B, dB/dt is
equal to, well it
can be formed through
my first order in A,
so that's k1 times
A. But it also
could get destroyed
by forming C.
So we've got to get
all the paths out
of A, here on the right
side of this equation.
So it can be destroyed
in a process, which
is first order in
B. So we're going
to take both k1 and k2 to
be first order initially.
Then we'll make one of them
second order and things will
become very complicated and
we'll throw up our hands.
But for now, let's not throw
up our hands quite yet.
OK and for dC/dt,
there's only one way
it can be formed is first
order by destroying B.
And we have a couple of
differential equations here.
This differential equation
for C, depends on B here.
The differential for
B depends on A here.
So that means that things are
going to get a little bit more
complicated.
The easy one to solve is
always the first one here.
That's first order.
So we just write
down the answer.
A is equal to A0, e
to the minus k1 t.
We know the answer to that one.
Then we have to work
on B. So we want
to find out integrated rate laws
for every one of these chemical
species.
And always there
are tricks involved.
Partial fractions, whatever.
So we write down
B now. dB/dt plus,
let me rearrange it a little
bit, plus k2 times B, putting
the minus k2 B on
the other side here.
Is equal to k1
times A. But I'm not
going to keep this A
there, because now I
know what A is in terms of time.
And a constant. k1 times A0
e to the minus k1 times time.
OK, that's my
differential equation
for B. Got to solve this thing.
Well, the last time I did
differential equations
in college was a century ago.
And I wasn't kidding.
It really was last century.
In fact, it was last millennium.
That was a long time ago.
So how do you do this?
Well, the trick here,
there's a trick.
And the trick is to multiply the
whole thing, both sides, by e
to the k2 t.
And you multiply this
side by e to the k2 t
and you multiply this
side by e to the k2 t,
to solve this equation.
So once you do
that, then you have
e to the k2 t times dB/dt plus
k2 times B. This side here.
And then you have is equal to
k1 times A0 e to the minus, e
to the k2 minus k1 times time.
OK, so the reason
why this trick works
is because this guy right
here can be nicely written
as d/dt of B times
e to the k2 t.
It's in nice simple form,
so when you integrate,
it'll be very easy to integrate.
And then the other
side, you still
have k1 A0 e to the k2
minus k1 times the time.
So now you integrate
both sides with respect
to time, The integral of
something d/dt with respect
to time, it's just going
to be itself right here.
So it's very simple.
So you integrate both sides
from zero to time, dt.
Zero to t, dt on both sides.
And on this side here,
you end up with B,
e to the k2 times time minus
B, e to the k2 times zero.
Just taking the upper limit
minus the lower limit.
And that's just equal to
B0, at time to equal zero.
And so, and at
time to equal zero,
B0 is equal to zero because we
haven't made any intermediates.
So this goes away.
And then we have an equals sign.
And on the other side, we
have k1 A0 over k2 minus k1,
it's just the integral
of this thing,
here with a k2 minus k1
goes in the denominator. e
to the k2 minus k1
times time minus one.
So now you have your integral
form for the amount of B
that gets created at any time.
And I want to keep
that on the board.
Because I'm going
to use it later.
k1 A0 over k1 minus k2 times
e to the minus k1 times
time minus e to the
minus k2 times time.
OK, we're two thirds
of the way through.
Now we've got to find C.
And for the last component,
you don't want to be
doing this kind of stuff.
You don't want to waste your
time solving differential
equations, because
stoichiometry can help you out.
At the end of the day,
you know that everything
that started out as A,
in terms of quantities,
is going to end up at C.
You know that if you end up
with a concentration
A0 at the beginning,
at the end of the process
the concentration of C,
at infinite time, is
also going to be A0.
If you know that
there's a correlation,
there's a stoichiometry that
relates A and C together.
And B. You have conservation
of mass here, basically.
Conservation of atoms.
That has to come into play
So, for C, we're just going to
do algebra instead of calculus.
So let's write down
the stoichiometry here.
The amount of C at
any time is what
it's going to be at the end.
Which is A0, very
end of the process.
It's going to be A0.
But before we get
to the end, there's
still stuff that's
left in A and B.
And that's going to
decrease the amount of C.
So minus whatever's
still in A and B.
That's the stoichiometry.
That's one way of writing it.
You could also write
it in a different way.
Which is that the amount of
C is equal to the amount of A
that you have used up.
A0 is what you started out with.
A is what's left over.
So this is the
amount of A used up.
It's not all quite in C yet.
Some of it is stuck in B.
So it's the amount of A used
up, minus the amount that's
stuck in B. Those
two are the same.
I hope.
A0 minus A, yeah, that's right.
Minus B, yeah, that's right.
So this is used up.
And then stuck in B.
That's the hard part.
Putting down the stoichiometry.
Once you've done
the hard part, then
if you solve the other
two then it's easy.
You just plug in.
It's just algebra.
And you get something
complicated.
C is equal to complicated.
It's in the notes, I'm not
going to write it down.
So we've solved the
problem exactly.
And now you're going
to do an experiment.
And the experiment
you're going to do
is not going to follow
this whole thing, exactly.
It's going to look
at limited cases.
That's what you can do.
And so the first
thing to look at
is to look at the initial times.
The very beginning
of the process,
how are things appearing.
And then we'll look
at the late times.
So initial times.
Near t equals zero.
Well, every one of these things
has an exponential in it.
And whenever we see exponentials
and we look at something
at the early times, times that
are faster than one over k1,
or faster than one over k2, it
tells us use a Taylor series.
So use the approximation
e to the minus kt
is approximately equal to
one minus kt plus kt squared
over two plus et cetera.
And keep as many terms as
you need in the Taylor series
to get something sensible.
So if everything comes
out of zero at the end,
you know you haven't
kept enough terms in t.
Things have canceled
out too much.
And you want something
that is time dependent.
Because you've got a
change in time, right?
It's a very common mistake
to say only keep one here
and then everything
cancels out you get zero,
and you say, well, B is
equal to zero at all times.
That's nonsensical.
And I don't know a priori
how much time to keep.
So let's go to second order.
So if you plug this
Taylor series into A,
and get something
that's time dependent,
you only need to
go to first order.
One minus k1 times
time plus et cetera.
Plug it into b, plug your
Taylor series into these two
guys here, get k1
A0 over k2 minus k1,
you only need it to
go to first order.
The one's cancel out but
the times don't cancel out.
Minus k1 plus k2, that is,
unless k1 and k2 are the same.
So we're making
the approximation
that k1 is different than k2.
Times the time.
And when we look at C,
this complicated thing
that I didn't write
down, if you were just
to stop at first order in
C, you get C equals zero.
You know that can't be right.
You know that C is going
to increase in time.
It can't be equal to
zero at all times.
So we have to go to
second order for C0.
And it's approximately equal to
A0 times k1 k2 over two times
the time squared.
Let me rewrite this a
little bit closer in,
because I need some room here.
So c is approximately
equal to A0 k1
is k2 over two
times time squared.
OK, and then we can
start plotting out
what this is going
to look like then.
So we have the concentrations
time on the axis here.
Let's start with the
concentrating of A. A
is dropping down
linearly in time.
It's dropping down
linearly in time here.
B is increasing linearly
in time, at the beginning.
So B is going up linearly
in time, like this.
And C is increasing
quadratically in time.
So it's pretty flat,
coming up first.
And then it starts to curve up.
It's our first approximation.
Then, we go to late
times. t equals infinity.
So t equals infinity where
am I going to write this?
Have to move this up.
Let's go, t goes to infinity.
Well, here I know that
I'm allowed to go to zero.
Or allowed to go to constant,
because infinity is forever.
So at t infinity, I know that
I'm going to use up all of A.
So I know that A is
going to be equal to 0.
I know I'm going
to use up all of B.
So I know B is
going to go to zero.
Somehow.
And I know that C is
going to go to A0.
So C is going to go
to A0 at infinity.
So now on my graph here,
I know that at infinity, A
is going to go down to
zero like this, somehow.
Probably exponentially, because
it is exponential in time.
So it's going to go
to zero exponentially.
B is going to go down
There are the
exponentials right here.
So B is going to go down
to zero exponentially.
Something like this.
And C is going to
saturate to A0.
Exponentially rise up to A0.
So this was A0 right here.
It's going to go like this.
So then I connect the dots.
And I know that C is going
to start quadratically.
And then it's going to rise
up an exponent like this.
I know that B is going
to start off linearly,
and then it has to go to zero.
So it has to go through
some sort of maximum.
And A is going to go
down exponentially,
exponentially like this.
So the interesting
part of this diagram
is that B goes to a maximum.
There is some point,
there's some time,
that we can call t sub B
max, where B is a maxima.
And that's an interesting point.
That's something that we can
try to figure out experimentally
what it is.
And we could get
some parameters,
we could maybe extract
some information.
There's a maximum B,
concentration of B,
that gets formed.
And how do you solve that?
You set dB/dt equal to zero.
So you have your equation
for B right here.
You set it equal to
zero. and you solve.
You get your maximum time.
It's made up of rate constant.
You get your maximum
concentration,
which is also made
up of rate constants.
And you can get rate
constants out of this.
Question.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yes.
PROFESSOR: That
is a coincidence.
That is my poor sketching.
It should probably be somewhere
like, in the middle here.
Actually, it completely
depends on the rates.
And we're going to
see limiting cases
where this maximum
can occur here,
or it can occur
somewhere down here.
So this is the complete case.
So, limiting cases. the
important limiting cases.
We've made an
approximation along the way
that k1 is different than k2.
So that has to be a case
that needs to be worked out.
And it's likely to be easier
than the full solution.
So one of the limiting
cases is k1 is equal to k2
and I'll leave
that for homework.
You can do that yourselves.
It's good exercise.
What about another
limiting case?
Well, you have two
other limiting cases.
One, you've got two rates.
So, one is bigger
than the other.
No information on
this board here.
You start off with one case.
So k1 greater than k2.
k1 greater than k2.
What does it mean?
It means that the
rate determining
step, or the limiting
step, in this reaction,
is the second step. k2 is
very slow compared to k1.
And sometimes I like to think
of these things as pipes.
And connecting vessels.
So let's say we have
the amount of liquid
in the top vessel is
the concentration of A.
The amount of liquid
in the middle vessel,
let me get my color scheme
to be consistent here.
Then we have a
middle vessel, which
is the concentration of B,
and a final vessel, which
is the concentration
of C. And we start out
with some sort of
amount of A in here.
Started with a lot of A,
and then these vessels
are connecting with pipes.
So there's a very
thick, big pipe
that connects A and B together.
The rate is fast,
going from A to B.
And the rate going
from B to C is slow,
so there's a skinny pipe
connecting B and C together.
Then I turn on the
system, I set time
to equal zero,
poof, what happens?
There's the big pipe
connecting A and B.
The whole amount of a here gets
transferred to B, suddenly.
Then it gets stuck here.
And then it dribbles
out from B to C.
So what do we expect,
if we were to plot
our quantities as
a function of time.
What we'd expect
then, then we're
going to make sure that
the math works out,
is that A is going to
decrease really fast.
It's going to go, poof.
First order in time
with a very fast rate.
And all of this is going
to go straight into B.
So we expect B to go linearly.
Remember, at the
beginning it's linear.
Linear goes up.
Almost all the way up to A0.
Because it can't hardly get out.
Reaches its maximum,
then it goes from B to C
through this
skinny, skinny pipe.
First order rate,
with a rate k2,
so we're exponentially going
down, slowly, slowly, slowly,
with a rate k2.
And then C starts quadratically.
And then very quickly,
once everything's into B,
A is forgotten.
A doesn't matter any more.
Basically what you're
looking at is a transfer of B
into C through this little pipe.
And you know that's going
to be a first order of rate.
First order of process,
B to C's first order
of process with rate k2.
So you expect, then, C to
go up in the first order
process to A0 with rate k2.
There's the rate k2 here.
And the rate k1 here.
So when you turn the crank on
your approximation in the math,
what you'd better see
is that at the end,
B as a function of
time should look
like a first order
process with rate k2.
C as a function of time
should look like a first order
process with rate
k2, going to A0.
And you can write
the answer, you
should be able to
write the answer,
for C, it's going to
be C is approximately,
it's going to go to A0,
there's no other choice.
Everything that was in A gets
transferred to B0, so at time
is infinity it's going
to be A0, and it's
going to be a first order
process with rate k2.
One minus e to the
minus k2 times times.
I don't even have
to do the math.
I know that's the answer.
If you don't believe
me, then do the math.
You should do it.
But that's the answer.
It has to be the answer.
And if you look at
B, the answer has
to be that it's approximately
looking like B is disappearing
with a rate constant that's
k2, e to the minus k2,
and the maximum here
is very close to A0.
So I'm going to be
putting A0 here.
Close enough.
So as long as I ignore the
very initial time where
A suddenly dumps into B, then
everything after that very
early time here is just
looking like B goes to C.
This is not zero, this is t.
And A just disappears quickly.
And we can write it as A is
equal to A0 e to the minus
k1 times the time.
That's an easy approximation.
And you've just got to
make sure that this fits.
So the other limiting
case, which I'm also
going to leave as a
homework, because it's
so straightforward, is to
have k2 greater than k1,
and you should make sure
that you can predict it.
and that the math works out.
OK, any questions?
Next time we'll do
reversible reactions.
And some more approximations.